i'm alejandra Ranga research engineer at
MIT and I am mark Drella a professor at
MIT and we'll be giving the 16 1 10 X
flight vehicle aerodynamics course this
is based on a course which has been
taught at the MIT Department of
aeronautics and astronautics for some
time it's targeted primarily towards
first-year graduate students however
advanced undergraduates have taken the
course as well the online version will
also target Professional Engineers wish
to brush up on their aerodynamic
expertise and knowledge this is not a
course in handbook aerodynamics it
assumes that you already have some
knowledge of basic aerodynamics and if
you're comfortable talking about Mach
number Reynolds numbers then this course
is probably for you what we will give
you is the tools you'll need to think
about editing problems in a sound way
and we hope to give you an intuitive
feel for Erik flows and how to behave in
real applications the focus is on
aerodynamic modeling the modeling
concepts the methods and the
mathematical tools where you will gain
will be the ability to better understand
computational and experimental results
and also rational means to estimate lift
drag and aerodynamic interference you'll
also gain an understanding of how
boundary layers limit aerodynamic
performance in general we will cover
many topics in this course including
concepts related to potential flows
effects of boundary layers on potential
flows Force analysis drag breakdown and
related concepts and we also delve into
compressible flows including transonic
and supersonic flows and we'll also
cover unsteady flows along the way we
will discuss some techniques used in
wind tunnel testing
finally we will discuss air tank models
used in flight dynamics and in fact this
course will serve as a good introduction
to flight dynamics if you've never been
exposed to that before hopefully you now
have some idea about what's courses all
about and we hope you'll join us